DAVID TAYLOR GOMES:
Students in high school,
there's this feeling
of suffocation,
of everyone trying to tell you
you have to be
the absolute best.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
KYLE HOLMES:
Students truly believe
that their class rank
and where they go to college
is gonna determine everything.
STUDENT:
A 4.0 isn't enough anymore,
which is funny 'cause
that used to be perfect.
But now, it's all about
being better than perfect.
♪ What the hell, what the hell
Is going on here? ♪
HOLMES:
In writing the musical Ranked,
we wanted to amplify
everything our students
were saying to us.
There's a huge pressure
to keep up GPA
while balancing drama
and being on a sports team
and the National Honor Society.
HOLMES:
At a school like Granite Bay,
everyone knows
where everyone is rank-wise.
Technology has made it
so prevalent.
Kids are oftentimes
finding themselves
very miserable.
♪ When does this feeling
Go away? ♪
♪ This tightness in my chest ♪
SPEAKER:
Most parents don't know.
I think this show
started conversations.
GOMES: We had
schools all over the country
reaching out to us,
wanting to license
and perform the show.
From California to West Virginia
to New York.
HOLMES: Saying, "Hey, these are
our kids' stories too,"
and "How can we work with you
to tell that?"
GOMES: But then...
ANNOUNCER: (OVER PA)
School will be closed
in response to
the COVID-19 virus.
SPEAKER 2: For a lot of kids,
theater is where they find
the place where they belong.
Can't do theater very well
with a mask on your face.
HOLMES: And then we realized
there was no reason
Ranked couldn't be adapted
online.
SPEAKER 3: The arts is our glue
during this pandemic.
♪ I'm gonna come up for air ♪
♪ I can't keep pretending ♪
For our communities,
education is your key
to success.
SPEAKER 3:
College represents a way
to raise their economic state.
♪ Happy endings have a cost ♪
SPEAKER 4: Opportunities
are not evenly given out
in this world.
SPEAKER 5: Our students
are growing up where
they're experiencing racism,
oppression.
SPEAKER 6: It's scary to see
how the world really is.
♪ Why do I always feel
so forgotten? ♪
STUDENT 2: I can't let
the pressure stop me.
I still have to live my dreams.
♪ Just breathe ♪
STUDENT 3: Theater,
it gives me hope.
GOMES: I think this show
is a bit of a wake-up call.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES, CONCLUDES) ♪